le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais la réunion
regorge d'endroits naturel de zones
encore sauvage épargné de la main de
l'homme
ces espaces sauvages appelé e n s pour
espaces naturels sensibles font parler
de la réunion à travers le monde
une richesse si unique que lille a été
inscrite au patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité par l'unesco pour plus de 40
% de sa superficie
une preuve incontestable qu'il faut
préserver ces espaces naturels sensibles
propriété du conseil général
mais ce n'est pas une raison pour en
faire un musée
au contraire le département souhaite que
la population s'approprie ces espaces il
fait donc le nécessaire pour que la
majorité des réunionnais puissent
profiter de ses richesses
mais il reste une minorité de personnes
comme les personnes handicapées ou les
personnes à mobilité réduite qui ne
peuvent pas toujours profité de ces
endroits
alors comment préserver ces lieux
exceptionnels et les rendre accessibles
à tous on en parle maintenant d'un lien
social
c'est sur le site de dioré à saint-andré
que ce groupe de personnes se préparent
pour profiter d'un moment agréable en
pleine nature
si la promenade se fait avec une
joëlette c'est que certaines de ces
personnes sont handicapées ou à mobilité
réduite
pourtant elles vont pouvoir se balader
dans un espace naturel sensible réputés
difficiles d'accès grâce à la volonté du
conseil général
un nombre croissant de neiges sont
aménagés pour devenir accessible à tous
tout le temps et bien sûr pendant les
manifestations comme la fête de la
nature et veut nous avons été sollicités
par le conseil général dans le cadre de
l'organisation de cette manifestation
sur des espaces naturels sensibles plus
particulièrement sur les sites où le
conseil général a décidé de privilégier
les personnes à mobilité réduite à
savoir le studio est là où nous sommes
aujourd'hui le site de sainte marguerite
vendredi et le site longement samedi
cias et troisième sur le présent nous
avons emmené des joëlettes c'est un
moyen de déplacement et des personnes à
mobilité réduite
le conseil général a pour volonté
d'offrir les mêmes services à tous les
réunionnais sans exception les personnes
handicapées ou à mobilité réduite
doivent donc avoir accès à tous les
services publics y compris aux loisirs
le conseil général met l'accent sur
cette accessibilité pour les sites les
personnes et je dirais en situation de
handicap parce que nous sommes tous
potentiellement dans une situation de
handicap parce qu'il est important de
faire découvrir cette île à à tous ses
habitants
l'accessibilité est une obligation dans
les espaces ceux recevant le public dans
les villes dans les aménagements urbains
et c est nous au conseil général on a
voulu que cette accessibilité soit aussi
effective sur les sentiers de randonnées
dans les espaces naturels parce que la
réunion c'est aussi des espaces naturels
la réunion c'est les montants
c'est des sentiers c'est les balades à
travers la nature et c'est ça la réunion
pour tous la réunion accessible le site
de dioré aujourd'hui est un exemple il y
à aussi la forêt de bélouve où il y à
des balades de proposer et on travaille
en partenariat il faut le souligner avec
des associations qui vont mettre à notre
disposition par la disposition du public
des joëlettes ça permet aux personnes
qui sont à mobilité réduite de pouvoir
profiter des sentiers des espaces des
grands espaces de la réunion pour
nassimah dindar s'est tout simplement
normal que tout le monde puisse avoir
accès à l'ensemble des lieux publics de
la réunion une conviction qu'elle tient
à transmettre à l'ensemble des agents du
conseil général et au delà à l'ensemble
des réunionnais nous aménageons les
pistes de randonnées pour que tous les
réunionnais puissent faire des
excursions marché et nous avons depuis
quelques années à ménager 18 ce site n
est ce les espaces naturels sensibles
que nous devons valoriser réservés parce
que c'est la beauté et la richesse de la
réunion et conseil général nous sommes
fiers d'avoir ouvert la moitié de ces
ems à l'ensemble des personnes en
situation de handicap parce que elles
aussi elles ont besoin d'écouter les
oiseaux chantent et de parcourir ces
sentiers et d'aller dans la rosée grand
matin voir l'art et la richesse de ses
espaces naturels sensibles fait de la
réunion un endroit unique au monde
le conseil général continue de soutenir
tous les acteurs dns qui se battent pour
faire de notre département un endroit
original de par sa biodiversité et ses
espèces endémiques
à découvrir par tous tout au long de
l'année le conseil général de la réunion
vous a présenté lien social le conseil
général aux côtés des réunionnais